good morning Hank it's Tuesday so I'm on
vacation in Michigan right now and the
days here unspool in a kind of slow
motion I read and write and hang out
with my family and stare out at this
great lake which to the human eye might
as well be an ocean since it stretches
up all the way to the horizon I love a
good horizon line I remember as a kid
wondering what would happen if you
sailed out to the horizon I mean I knew
the world was round and everything but
it sure looked like it ended like if you
sailed far enough you'd be in the sky
and then as I got older I realized you
could chase the horizon forever and
never actually get to it which gave me
this weird kind of comfort I find it
hard to describe one of my favorite
artists is the Japanese photographer
Hiroshi Sugimoto and he has a series of
photographs called seascapes where he
photographed water horizons all over the
world from the Tasman Sea to the
Caribbean to the Sea of Japan to the
Baltic to the Mediterranean to Lake
Superior tsujimoto has said that water
and air vouchsafe for our very existence
and maybe that's the comfort I feel
looking out at a water horizon maybe I
feel my existence vouchsafed these days
seeing the hard line of the horizon
makes me think not about the edge of the
world but about the edge lessness of it
the world is a globe Terry Pratchett
wrote the farther you sail the closer to
home you are like our dad grew up in
Indianapolis back when its nickname was
nap town because nothing ever happened
there it was a place that attracted
people who actively wanted to live quiet
lives in the flat and unbeautiful middle
of America the kind of way snick caraway
could retreat to at the end of the Great
Gatsby after being unable to bear the
awful excitement of New York our dad
worked like hell to get out of
Indianapolis he and mom left for good a
few weeks after I was born and never
looked back and then in 2007 Sarah and I
were living in New York and I called dad
with the news Sarah had gotten a job I
told him in well in Indianapolis and he
said you can't be serious
I'd sailed away from a birth place I
never really knew to Orlando and
Birmingham Chicago and New York and
ended up right back where I started I
used to think of that as a failure that
I'd ended up back in the middle
Midwesterners sometimes called the Great
Lakes the Third Coast or we brag that
our Great Sea is unsalted and Sharklets
but we know that our lakes are not as
grand as the coastal oceans I felt I had
failed because I wasn't looking out at
the greatest horizon or swimming with
the strongest current or battling the
biggest waves
I used to think that even though you
could never get to the horizon you had
to keep chasing it your whole life that
in fact the point of life was to chase
after the unreachable horizon I used to
think that Moby Dick's Captain Ahab who
loses everything in pursuit of that
great white whale was the only proper
hero in American fiction but now Hank I
find myself content utterly content to
look at the horizon rather than chase
after it I like the middle I'm happy
here at this lake which can trick my
eyes into believing it goes on forever I
think I've underrated happiness and also
underrated the pleasure of just
observing so thanks for watching with me
Hank I'll see you on Friday